what about pick up to Intel so there was
a cool paper from a few years back
called uh I don't I don't think the
title was the insa P rated in cell
pipeline but that's basically what it
described it might have been called
mapping the manosphere or something like
that so this used network analysis and
it looked at something like 52 forums
that were red pill forums mgtow forums
manosphere forums Pua on Reddit and then
it looked at some of the big big uh
forums online outside of Reddit as well
and it used content analysis to kind of
identify users or identify the kind of
discourse and content and track how
those moved over time and as as far as
active users and active discussions and
stuff so a lot of the Pua and red pill
forums
they declined and then in cell forums
boom they appear on on the timeline and
already they're beating everyone else
and they're looking at users that
basically migrated from one to another
and you see a lot of cross-migration in
the discourse from those early Pua forms
to the later in cell forums and so the
idea from that is kind of like okay a
lot of people began in Pua communities
and they moved into these in-cell
communities similarly a lot of people
that began in these red pill communities
they now have a lot of overlap with the
mgtow communities which mgtow is of
course men going their own way men who
do not want to date
kind of similar to incels kind of not so
you see these communities that began
kind of like a self-improvement and
gaining advice for men like hey you want
to be with women and you want to date
and we're going to give you like the
tools for that and maybe they didn't
work you know because now all of the men
have gone to these communities that said
no we're going our own way now we don't
want to date or oh we're just in sales
now either way why do you think that
this is the trajectory that seems to be
happening
so I think something that you said was
that even if Pua is successful it can be
kind of dispiriting to people so say you
start Pua and you actually kind of have
a little bit of success with it there's
I think there's a question to be made is
like is this helping people form lasting
romantic relationships or are these just
kind of moving people into that
promiscuous ten percent because this
cohort this permission was 10 so to
speak this is associated with a lot of
uh personality issues people that are
very very promiscuous risk-taking It's
associated with things like higher
scores and dark Triad personality and
all of that and these are individuals
that because they are so promiscuous or
not because kind of as a correlate to
that they might not be forming long-term
relationships they might have a hard
time forming those connections if your
sexual partner is a very promiscuous
probably you know that's associated with
more infidelity so something I noticed
observing red pill forms and P waveforms
A lot of these people were like oh you
know someone cheated on me someone
cheated on me all of my girlfriend and
cheated on me and at that point I have
to kind of Wonder like why what kind of
people are you selecting where like all
of your girlfriends have cheated on you
and then they end up you know the men
that started early in that and ended up
later with these very cynical and jaded
views and it's like okay but your own
experience is selecting people might
have kind of shaped that trajectory for
you in a sense and then at the same time
there are many men who probably entered
those communities Pua or something and
got no results at all and I think those
are a lot of the people that have gone
to uh blackfield communities in fact I
think even one of the early in-cell
forums was actually called Pua hate
right yes yes yes and and I only
reminded remember that because I was
listening to your show with uh with Nama
Kates today yeah so certainly these were
people that had experiences of Pua stuff
and they thought oh this is you know not
going to work for me it didn't work for
me it's a rift I paid the money and
maybe I didn't get the results that I
wanted and boom they're going you can
see how that would be a black pill right
you're telling me that the guy with the
big furry hat and the massive sideburns
mystery out of Neil Strauss is the game
even he could get laid with his stupid
hair and his flares and oh and now the
real social dynamics Tyler and Max and
everybody else they've come along and
they're not not all of them were exactly
you know the Pinnacle of Giga Chad
masculinity and it worked for them and
it hasn't worked for me therefore I
should find distaste with this yeah I am
I can completely see why that would
cause people to Cascade down from Hope
to increasing gradations of hopelessness
absolutely and and I think there's a
personality trait that is closely
associated with that which is resilience
so some people they can get rejected a
thousand times and it just brushes off
of them you know like like water off of
a duck's back then get rejected over and
over and over they have very very high
resilience and it doesn't affect them if
they get cheated on they just move on to
a new relationship if they experience a
divorce they get married again these are
people that from their past experiences
they don't let it uh sit upon them in a
sense and other people uh you know their
girlfriend cheats on them they're
they're in love when they're 18 and they
break up with their first girlfriend and
it just devastates them and they never
get over it again so kind of very low
resilience in that sense and I think if
someone is going from a position of very
low resilience say they go into Pua and
they're like okay I want you to approach
a thousand women they go to the
supermarket or the mall and they
approach 100 women or whatever and they
get rejected a hundred times uh that's
going to shape the perception of someone
with very low resilient very differently
from someone who who doesn't care
remember what we were talking about
earlier on which is that most people are
a
non-insignificant cohort of people are
not seeking relationships at the moment
more people seem to be risk-averse more
people are spending more time online
than ever before when you combine all of
this together what you end up with are
people who are less resilient having to
them traumatic experiences that can
sometimes be pre-selected due to their
them being the common denominator
between all of the abusive manipulative
cheating girlfriends or boyfriends or
whatever it is that they do then the
large cohort of people online who aren't
disproving any of these theories in the
real world see stories on Reddit that
quite rightly Garner tons and tons of
upvotes because they're shocking this
here's the guy who left for milk and
came back and his wife was having sex
with the neighbor and the dog at the
same time and she left him and took all
of his money and now he's got Crohn's
disease and you know he's living on the
street and he's gluten intolerance and a
club foot like all of these things have
happened to this one guy oh my God this
is why all women are [__] right like
all women are like that
one of the problems or one of the things
that I see online especially when it
comes to trying to encourage guys to get
into a long-term committed relationship
especially one that encourages marriage
is that they would say why would I get
into a relationship like a woman's just
going to take all of my money and do
this thing in any case okay did that
happen to you
or did you read one story or a small
number of stories online that told you
that this is something that's super
super common because dude even the heads
of the red pill movement like even the
most red pilly of red pill guys get into
[__] long marriage relationships like
Neil Strauss the guy that wrote the game
is now this completely renewed Tucker
Max the guy that invented the entire
genre of fratia lives 30 miles away from
me at a ranch in [__] Dripping
Springs surrounded by he's made a
Waldorf School for his kids and him and
his wife have got four and he spends his
days practicing shooting guns and
corralling and stuff oh yeah that's
that's really the the future that he had
planned for himself at the age 25 wasn't
it no of course not like obviously not
even the people that were previously
supposed to be the figureheads of these
entire movements have transcended and
included their experience to now become
family men and yet there is still a very
very common
distaste reticence bitterness uh
toxicity toward that long-term dating
thing again this is obviously not for
either of us to say that some guys
haven't got themselves into
relationships with women who have
destroyed their lives who were the
Machiavellian manipulative that he was
perfectly fine and she took him for all
that he was worth like yep yep that
happens and to those guys I have the
absolute utmost sympathy
um but the fact that those stories are
so egregious online and Garner's so much
like
attention is for precisely the reason
that they feel so outrageous that they
are less
representative of most normal
relationships and yeah I I don't really
know what the solution is for this
because for as long as people will take
their cues about what the mating Market
is like from the internet and don't
disprove it in the real world due to
their concern and lack of resilience or
just general fear for any one of the
Myriad of reasons that we've said both
men and women women are going to believe
that every man out there is a potential
rapist and men out there are going to
believe that every woman is a spinster
that wants to take him for 50 of his
wealth
exactly yeah and something you mentioned
that's very important many of these are
very very young men you said have you
experienced a divorce these are some of
these men are 18 19 20 years old you
know have they even experienced a
breakup at that point they do not need
to be worrying about someone taking
their house if they don't even have a
job and they don't have a house and
they're living in the basement and that
sort of a thing baby steps first
worrying about forming a relationship
becoming resilient to deal with breakups
because most relationships will end you
know everyone who gets into relationship
experiences a bunch of breakups you know
that's something that happens to
everyone and worry about the divorce
down the line so you have you know men
going their way mgto if you are like 45
years old and you've been through two
divorces and you're mgtow I totally
understand that like maybe you you are
done with dating and that's kind of
reasonable if you're 18 years old and
you've only had one girlfriend and never
had a girlfriend how have you sworn off
women already that's not reasonable
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full all
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]